salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux j'adore l'ouvrir
l'huître est aussi l à déguster
comme les deux tiers des français quelle
que soit la saison je ne résiste pas à
leurs parfums et leur petit goût iodé en
plus on leur prête beaucoup de vertus
on les dit même aphrodisiaques casanova
paraît-il en manger in google chaque
matin alors info ou intox on va essayer
d'y voir plus clair
fait chaud aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il existe deux variétés d'huîtres en
france les huîtres plates
et les huîtres creuses blatt creuse ça
se voit non les premières à vivait en
nombre le long des côtes françaises
jusqu'au 19ème siècle malheureusement
elles ont été victimes de leur succès et
aussi de maladies du coup elles sont
devenues rares aujourd'hui elles sont
encore élevés en bretagne ce sont les
fameuses belon par exemple du nom d'un
petit fleuve côtier à l'embouchure de
quelle elle se développe ses huîtres ont
été remplacés le long des côtes et dans
nos assiettes par des huîtres creuses
d'abord par une espèce originaire du
portugal puis par une espèce originaire
des côtes japonaises
pour vasile contre uc si vous aimez les
huîtres big man lesquels vous préférez
en attendant un peu d'histoire
ça fait longtemps qu'on aime les huîtres
au 19e siècle louis xviii en consommer
tellement qu'on le surnommait
louis xviii un de ses prédécesseurs ont
mis quinze les aime tant qu en 1727 il
commande un tableau articuler le
déjeuner l'huître il est exécuté par le
peintre jean françois de troy est
destiné à orner la salle à manger des
petits appartements de versailles
j'adore ce tableau il figurait dans les
livres d'histoire quand j'étais
collégien il est plein de vie on y voit
d'ailleurs l'une des premières
représentations d'une bouteille de
champagne on aura sûrement l'occasion
d'y revenir il est aujourd'hui visible
au musée condé à chantilly à l'époque
les camions frigorifiques n'existe pas
les huîtres sont transportés en
charrettes tirées par des choses la
route est longue entre 24 et 36 heures
pour faire la liaison dieppe l'hiver ça
va mais l'été quand les huîtres arrivent
dans la capitale elles ne sont plus
toutes fraîches d'autant qu'à l'époque
les huîtres ne sont pas toujours vendu
dans leur coquille et mitry ou à gagner
comme on dit c'est à dire des coquilles
et pour être mangés en ragots pour
lutter contre les intoxications causées
par le coquillage pendant la belle
saison oui 15 interdit donc la pêche le
colportage ou la vente des huîtres de la
fin avril à la fin août pas d'huîtres
les mois sans rc l'origine d'un usage
qui à l'otan durée même si aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus aucun risque à manger des
huîtres l'été à condition bien sûr de
respecter à la chaîne du froid
bon je te rappelle qu on voudrait savoir
si les huîtres sont aphrodisiaque et
pour le moment c'est pas très sexy ton
histoire l'histoire d'amour avec
l'huître ne date pas d'aujourd'hui pour
la soupçonne d'avoir des effets sur la
libido depuis l'antiquité
venus serait selon certains auteurs
l'incarnation humaines de la perle du
coup elle ne serait pas sorti d'une côte
saint jacques comme lapin de botticelli
mais d'une huître bon ok mais alors
qu'est ce que je fais je me change où je
reste dans cette tenue à ta place je ne
changerais jusqu'à présent les
scientifiques n'ont pas pu prouver que
consommer des huîtres augmente le désir
sexuel sa réputation aphrodisiaques
n'est donc pas fondée
en revanche sans les roms de chaire de 8
soit l'équivalent de 8 à 2,8
2,8 huîtres pas facile à dire apporte
plus de 20 mg de zinc c'est beaucoup les
nutritionnistes en recommande un apport
quotidien de deux milligrammes pour les
hommes et pour les femmes et que le
rapport est bien les scientifiques ont
montré que cet oligo éléments
contribuent chez les hommes à maintenir
un niveau plus élevé de testostérone
l'hormone associé à la sexualité et à la
fertilité masculine et puis ils ont
aussi noté que chez les souris le zinc
augmente le nombre de spermatozoïdes et
leur mobilité mais rien de plus
quoi qu'il en soit ce ne doit pas vous
empêcher de manger des huîtres
ce qui est certain c'est que les huîtres
sont riches en vitamines b à en faire en
fosse forte en cuivre en oméga 3 en iode
elles sont faibles en calories elle
affiche une bonne teneur en protéines
bref à défaut de pimenter votre libido
elle boosteront vos menus par leurs
bienfaits avec 2 kg par personne et par
an en moyenne les français sont les
premiers consommateurs d'huîtres au
monde tous vous aimiez les huîtres ou
non n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo est à
vous abonner
quant à moi je vous laisse il faut que
je participe à l'effort collectif pour
garder la tête du classement
elle affiche une bonne teneur reprêter
protéines passa en protéines allez
on tournait pas rond
[Applaudissements]